[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Hi, I'm Jessica.
LUKE DAVIS: And I'm Luke.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And we're
part of the developer relations
team for Actions on Google, and
welcome to Behind the Actions,
where today we're
going to be building
a really fun action with Luke.
LUKE DAVIS: We thought
that we would show off
some of the cool
things that you can
do, in terms of
user affordances,
by building a Silicon
Valley horoscope app.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That's awesome.
Wait, look-- what
are user affordances?
What does that mean?
LUKE DAVIS: That's
a great question.
So user affordances
are the sorts
of things that you put in
your application or action
to make it just smooth
and easy for the user
to get what they want out of
the thing that you've built.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I love that.
Yeah, it's all about making
it easier for the user.
LUKE DAVIS: So today, in
terms of user affordances,
we're going to include some cool
things, like suggestion chips
and user storage to
remember specific things
about each individual
user as they return to us.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Fantastic.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah,
and we're going
to nest this inside this
crazy project that's
going to replace the normal
Zodiac signs of Capricorn
and Scorpio with a few
Silicon Valley archetypes.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Like what?
LUKE DAVIS: Like product manager
and executive an engineer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Or designer.
I love it.
That sounds like fun.
So we're going to have custom
horoscopes for these different
archetypes-- their signs--
and giving them a
horoscope that's
going be consistent
with the day,
so it'll be the same
horoscope every day,
or-- not every day, I'm sorry.
For that day, it
would be the same one,
but every day will be different.
LUKE DAVIS: Exactly.
Just like you would
expect a horoscope to be.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, that make sense.
And if you're not familiar
with the tools of Dialogflow
or using intents.
We're going to make that
assumption that you've already
seen episode 1, so if you
don't know about that,
please go to our Behind
the Actions episode 1
and check that out.
So we're going to start off
by jumping in and building
our first project on the
Actions on Google console.
So here, we're going to click
on that and make a project.
And we're going to
call this Horoscope.
LUKE DAVIS: Horoscope
is very hard
to spell, for me personally.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Me too.
Did I spell that right?
LUKE DAVIS: I think so.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK, sweet.
OK, we're going to
create the project.
And what's happening
here is it's just
creating a project on the
Actions on Google console,
and it's going to drop
us right into the home
page of the project itself.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
And then we'll have
a bunch of options,
and Jessica is going to expertly
navigate these options to get
us all set up.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, so
we're going to pick a category.
We're going to scroll down
and do conversational,
because this is kind of a
unique demo that we're doing.
And then in here?
LUKE DAVIS: And then from here--
what I like to do when I'm
building these sorts of things
is have two tabs open
at the same time.
On one side, I'll have
the web simulator,
and that will let me like
test out my voice action
while I'm actually building it.
On the other side, I'll
have the Dialogflow console.
So Dialogflow is this
really great tool
that we have for building out
natural language applications.
It lets us set
intents and entities
and handle contexts and all
kinds of other cool things
you can learn about from
some of our other videos.
Lovely.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: There we go.
So now we created the it, and
so we create the actual project.
LUKE DAVIS: So
you don't actually
need to write any code at all
to use Dialogflow for managing
natural language processing.
but, if you do want
to be especially cool
and write some
code, you can just
go over to that Fulfillment
section on the left, and--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Well, before we go there,
let's change our
welcome, so then we
can have it hit our code.
LUKE DAVIS: Do you
want to do that first?
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah,
let's do that first.
And then we could
show what that is.
And so we'll go into our welcome
intent, and then in here,
there's training phrases,
all that great jazz.
We're going to scroll
all the way down.
And we don't want these
four to be our greetings.
LUKE DAVIS: That's right.
These being the text
responses there.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Mm-hmm.
And so I'm going to
delete that, and now we're
going to add fulfillment
for this intent.
LUKE DAVIS: So
Jessica just toggled
on the "Enable webhook call
for this intent" switch,
and what that does
is it says, OK,
when a user hits the
default welcome intent,
I'm going to shuttle
them along to my own code
for handling what the action
should say in response.
And so Jessica is just going
to click on the Fulfillment
section on the left
hand navigation
and toggle that Disabled
switch to Enabled.
And what this is
going to let us do
is build out the
fulfillment code
that we need for our
action right here
in the web console itself.
That means we don't need to
stand up our own server on GCP.
You don't need to think
about any of that stuff.
All you need to do is go
in here and start coding.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
And I'm just copy-pasting
from our boilerplate
code that's on our GitHub repo.
And so here we have the intent
of the default welcome intent,
and then we have a
conv.ask "Hello world!",
so let's change
that to be something
a little more appropriate.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh,
that's a great idea.
What should we use?
It should be something
like "Welcome
to Silicon Valley Horoscope!"
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Welcome to Silicon--
LUKE DAVIS: Silicon.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
With no "e," right?
LUKE DAVIS: No "e."
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
--Valley-- oops.
Valley Horoscope!
LUKE DAVIS: I
actually had no idea
that those were two different
words until Jessica educated me
last week.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
To get started--
LUKE DAVIS: Just
tell us your sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Just tell us your sign.
Sweet.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
All right.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK, and
so now we'll hit Deploy.
That way it could spin
up Firebase for us.
It's going to push all
our code over there.
It's going to do all of-- it's
going to set all the libraries,
and then it's going to grab--
once it's deployed and live,
it's going to grab the
URL and then actually
connect it to Dialogflow.
So it might take a
couple of seconds
for all that magic to happen.
And that's A-OK.
LUKE DAVIS: Usually
when you start up
this for the first
time, it'll take
longer for the first deployment
than any subsequent deployment.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, totally.
Because it's doing all
of that heavy lifting.
And then after that, it's
just pushing up the code,
and it makes it a lot faster.
LUKE DAVIS: That's right.
Easy peasy.
Now that that's
all deployed, we're
going to go over into the
Actions on Google web simulator
to test out the changes that
we've made to our action.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So we're
going through Integration.
That way, we can connect
this to our action.
And this is going to
drop us into the Actions
on Google simulator.
LUKE DAVIS: Right.
It'll give us a nice
little simulator,
not just for the little smart
speakers that you might have
sitting around your
house, but also for phones
and for smart displays.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK,
so now we can test it out.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
SYNTHESIZED VOICE 1: All right.
Here's the test
version of my test app.
SYNTHESIZED VOICE 2: Welcome
to Silicon Valley Horoscopes.
To get started, just
tell us your sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So ideally,
the user is going to be able
to say or find--
LUKE DAVIS: Let's say
it and see what happens.
Product manager.
SYNTHESIZED VOICE 2:
I didn't get that.
Can you repeat?
LUKE DAVIS: So
what's happening here
is our default fallback
intent is being triggered,
because we don't actually
have an intent set up
to handle when the user
says, I'm a product manager,
I'm a designer, I'm an engineer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, but most likely,
people are not going
to necessarily know
what options they have.
So maybe we should
do something to let
the user know these are
the options that they
have to pick from.
LUKE DAVIS: I think
that's a wonderful idea.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I'm
thinking suggestion chips.
LUKE DAVIS: That's great.
So Jessica's was going
to go back into our code,
and up at the very top,
where she imports the Actions
on Google library, she's also
going to import suggestions.
So suggestions are
super, super cool.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So it's
going to be Dialogflow come
in--
comma.
LUKE DAVIS: Comma.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
then suggestions otherwise.
Cool.
LUKE DAVIS: And so
those suggestion chips
are going to show up, if you're
looking at this on your phone
or on a smart display, as tiny
little lozenges at the bottom
that a user can click on.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Lozenges.
[LAUGHS] That's cute.
Instructions.
And so this going to
take an array of--
LUKE DAVIS: Just an
array of strings.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So we have PM.
And then what else we have?
LUKE DAVIS: We have engineers.
Engineer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Singular?
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, singular.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
then, who else do we got?
LUKE DAVIS: Designer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Designer.
LUKE DAVIS: And maybe executive.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Executive.
Exec--
LUKE DAVIS: E-X-E--
E-X-E-C-U-T-I-V.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Spelling is hard.
LUKE DAVIS: Spelling is hard.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
So we just have an
array of the options.
LUKE DAVIS: And we want
to close up params,
and then we'll be good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Cool.
Thank you.
There we go.
This is why I love pair
programming, because I always
forget something.
OK.
LUKE DAVIS: Sweet.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
so now, let's deploy this
and see how that looks.
LUKE DAVIS: We want
opening params there too.
That's why there
was an error here.
Sweet.
There we go.
I can't stop the deployment.
LUKE DAVIS: So we're
going to use this time
to think about what we want the
user interface of the action
to be.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, so
if I'm the action and I go,
Welcome, Luke, to
Silicon Valley Horoscope.
Tell me which one--
which horoscope you want.
Right?
And so I'm going to have
these little lozenges,
like these little
suggestion chips,
of PM, engineer,
executive, and designer.
Right?
And then you'll be able
to choose from that.
LUKE DAVIS: Right.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
LUKE DAVIS: And I will
say, for example, engineer.
And then you will say--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Then I should
give a really cool,
customized-for-engineers
horoscope.
LUKE DAVIS: Right.
Right.
Customized for engineers.
And it's a horoscope,
so we probably
want to have a
different one every day.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, so
we'll want to have to do that.
So I think we should just focus
on building out the response.
So we'll need to make a
new intent in Dialogflow
to capture whether
they are seeing
the different types of signs
that they could choose from.
LUKE DAVIS: You're
totally right.
And we're going to need to make
some way of capturing which
or those signs it is.
Right?
So it sounds like it's an
entity sort of solution.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, definitely.
So [INAUDIBLE].
I expected that versus that.
Oh, because I added--
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, there's two.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Wait, it's like this.
LUKE DAVIS: Mm-mm.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: No?
I'm missing-- I know
what I'm missing.
I'm missing--
LUKE DAVIS: The second params.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: There we go.
LUKE DAVIS: So I'm into params.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I know, yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: Come
on, [INAUDIBLE]..
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: There we go.
All right, cool.
So we'll go over here, and
then we'll create a new intent.
And this one should
be called something
to the effect of,
like, horoscope?
LUKE DAVIS: Horoscope?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
LUKE DAVIS: Select sign--
se-- s-- select sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Well,
they've already selected it,
so they are giving us the--
LUKE DAVIS: So when the-- right.
So when [INAUDIBLE]
welcome intent,
we say, or the action
says, "Why don't you
tell me what your sign is?"
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: And then the
user says, "I'm a designer,"
or whatever.
So that thing where they're
saying, "I'm a designer" is,
we want that to
trigger this intent.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Ah.
LUKE DAVIS: Right, so that's
the declaring sign or sign.
Maybe just sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Just sign?
LUKE DAVIS: Sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sign.
Sign.
Sign is simple.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sure.
Awesome.
OK, so we have that.
And if we go to our
training phrases,
we could put in
something like PM,
right, because that's one
of the suggestion chips.
LUKE DAVIS: Right,
we should probably
have all of the
suggestion chips verbatim
here in our training phrases.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right?
But right here, Dialogflow
doesn't know what a PM is--
LUKE DAVIS: That's true.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: --and
that it's important to us.
So let's actually
delete this intent
and actually make an entity
that you were mentioning before.
LUKE DAVIS: That's a great idea.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And that's
usually what happens to me.
As I'm building things, I'm
like, oh, I actually need this.
So let's go to entities,
and let's make a new one.
And so this entity should be--
LUKE DAVIS: Sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sign, right?
So this is the sign.
And so we have PM,
which could be set as--
LUKE DAVIS: Product
manager, yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: --as
PM or product manager.
LUKE DAVIS: Building a good
action is kind of like a--
it's kind of like a Samba.
You're like, a little bit
forward, and a little bit back.
And you're kind of like learning
the interface as you go along.
It's a more inherently
social sort of thing
than programming is
normally, I think.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Designer engineer PM,
and then executive--
LUKE DAVIS: Executive, yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
LUKE DAVIS: Sounds good to me.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Do we
need any synonyms for these?
LUKE DAVIS: Maybe for
executive, like exec.
I hear people using that.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Ooh,
how do you spell exec?
LUKE DAVIS: E-X-E-C, maybe?
Yeah, that sounds good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet, OK.
LUKE DAVIS: And then, under
engineer, maybe something
like developer or programmer?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Oh, mhm.
Developer.
LUKE DAVIS: Because
this is Silicon Valley.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
I think it looks good.
LUKE DAVIS: Sounds great to me.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
OK, so let's save this.
So we've made a custom entity.
Now we're going to
go to our intents
and then make the actual
intent that we have.
LUKE DAVIS: Right.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And so here do we still
want to call it a sign?
LUKE DAVIS: We already
called our intent--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Right,
now it feels like a little--
LUKE DAVIS: Let's call it--
let's call it select sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
There we go, select sign.
Like that?
LUKE DAVIS: Lovely.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
And then let's
add some training phrases?
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK, so this
is where we should have PM.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, look,
it already picked it up.
So Dialogflow is really smart.
If you've declared
an entity type
with a bunch of specific
synonym strings,
it'll know when
you go in and start
adding those kinds of
strings to your training
phrases of your intents that it
should recognize those entities
and extract them from
the user utterance.
Yeah, yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So I'm
just giving some random ones,
so ones where they just say
the sign itself, so PM--
I'm a developer.
I am a designer.
Give me the executive one.
So that we have a little
variety in the responses.
Ideally you want 10 to
15, but for this, it's
a demo, so we're going
to keep it as is.
LUKE DAVIS: Let's make sure
that we have all of the strings
that we used explicitly
there, like engineer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Ooh.
Well, I have designer on
here, so it should capture it.
But we could totally do that.
Engineer.
LUKE DAVIS: Lovely.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
LUKE DAVIS: Lovely, lovely.
And each of those
entities has already
been automatically
detected by Dialogflow.
So we should have
some confidence
that that's going pretty well.
So what Jessica's doing
now is she's saying,
hey, if the user doesn't
actually give you a sign,
then make sure that
we prompt them to.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: So
we'll do a reprompt,
and then here will be, "Please
pick from the following."
LUKE DAVIS: That sounds great.
So in your prompts, you want
to provide a little affordance
to the user about the options
that they can select from.
So we might say something like,
"I'm sorry, I didn't get that.
Did you mean to say engineer?"
Or something like that.
Or you could choose from among
product manager, executive,
engineer and designer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: That
sounds a lot more nicer
than what I wrote.
That's OK.
So from here, we don't
want to add responses here.
LUKE DAVIS: Right.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Because
then there won't be dynamic.
So let's add in the
fulfillment for this intent.
Sweet.
We'll hit save.
LUKE DAVIS: Lovely, lovely.
So Jessica and I
have been thinking
about this for a couple of days,
and we might have put together
a little code before the show
that will do the horoscope
composition magic for us.
So Jessica is just going
to deploy the code now.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yes.
LUKE DAVIS: And what it's doing
is, every sign and every day
will have a unique
horoscope that's assigned
to that sign on that day.
So if you come on Tuesday
and ask the horoscope system
for your horoscope and
you're an engineer,
you will always get the
same answer for that day
until the next day.
And it will be a different one.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: We're
doing this because--
well, for a few reasons.
The first is that
that's actually
the way that horoscopes work.
And the second is,
like, at a meta level,
we wanted to show off how you
can dynamically compose varying
responses, because in
a voice user interface,
unlike a graphical user
interface, if the user gets
exactly the same response
over and over and over again,
it can be quite jarring.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, it's frustrating.
Definitely.
LUKE DAVIS: Let's
describe a little bit
of what we're doing here.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah so we've
added a couple of libraries
that we will be using.
LUKE DAVIS: So
the salient one up
at the top, or the salient
two that we're doing,
are the Chance
library, which lets
you come up with a random--
really just a random number,
or selecting a random element
from an array.
Which doesn't sound
like that fancy,
except that Chance uses
the Twister algorithm.
It's a pseudo random
number generator such
that you can hand it a seed,
which is just any string
or number, and it
will always generate
exactly the same sequence of
random outputs after that.
Which is very useful
to us, because we
want to make sure that if
you come on Tuesday, like we
said before--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
It stays the same.
LUKE DAVIS: Exactly.
So we're using Chance for that.
And Handlebars is a
lovely templating library
that we can use to kind of
swap in different options
for the same bit of a horoscope.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
So I'm just scrolling down.
That way people can see.
Each horoscope is built with
three different elements.
So there's at feelings
element, an advance element,
and an opportunity, which is
very much like a horoscope.
That's kind of how they are.
LUKE DAVIS: And
we're just catting--
or concatenating-- each of those
sentences one onto the other
to compose the response.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
OK, so it's been deployed.
So let's go and jump in
and see if this works.
So now we're in
our test simulator.
I'm going to restart this.
LUKE DAVIS: Restart that.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And then
hit-- touch my test app.
COMPUTER: Sure.
Getting the test
version of my test app.
Welcome to Silicon
Valley Horoscope.
To get started, just
tell us your sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
So what is the sign?
LUKE DAVIS: Let's say,
yeah, that sounds great.
PM.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: PM.
COMPUTER: Your
horoscope for today
is everything is behind
schedule, and you feel anxious.
Ignore that.
By being honest with your team,
they will take pity on you
and maybe ship on time for once.
Would you like to hear the
horoscope for another sign?
LUKE DAVIS: It works!
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That's awesome.
Yay!
So we did have it on the visual
part, and so let's see how
the--
I'm sorry, with the audio
part and not the visual.
LUKE DAVIS: So Jessica
is going to-- yeah.
So Jessica's cursor
right there is
over the three possible
display options
that you can have when
using the web simulator.
That can be mobile on the left,
the center is a smart speaker,
and the thing on the
right is a smart display.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, I just made it
so then I wasn't overlapping
what you're talking about.
But you can see here, this
is what the visual will be.
Here are our suggestion chips.
Let's make it easier for it.
So I feel like we should
do the engineer one.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, let's
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah,
let's see what that one is.
COMPUTER: Your horoscope for
today is today is a great day.
Use your energy to
carry you forward.
Don't stress too much
about that P zero.
Today is a new chance to fix
all those horrible things
you did last quarter.
It's a good time to
refactor all that code
you pushed last Friday
before anyone notices.
Would you like to hear the
horoscope for another sign?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
This is awesome.
LUKE DAVIS: And now we
have the suggestion chips
down at the bottom that will
let you go back and forth.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, and we
did something special with this
one, with this suggestion
chip, where it's grabbing--
whatever current horoscope
that you're checking out,
it's not going to provide
it as a suggestion chip,
so we're actually editing
that part out, which is great.
That way the user--
generally you're
not going to want
to hear the same thing
over and over again.
So that way it makes it
just easier for the user.
LUKE DAVIS: Just another one
of those little affordances,
like we said, to the user,
to make their interaction
with the app that much easier.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
Sweet, OK so--
LUKE DAVIS: So I
noticed that we also
have a "No thanks" suggestion
chip down there at the bottom.
Does that do anything yet?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Let's click on it.
COMPUTER: I didn't get that.
Can you say it again?
LUKE DAVIS: So this, again,
triggered our default fallback
intent, because it didn't
match one of the intents
we had before.
We want to make an easy
exit route for users
once they've found the horoscope
or horoscopes that they wanted.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
So it sounds like we have
to make our end intent.
LUKE DAVIS: That sounds good.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: The
intent to finish the things.
So let's go back to Dialogflow.
And then in here, we're
going to go to intents.
And then we'll
create a new intent.
And here we're going
to call this one "end."
LUKE DAVIS: That sounds great.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
And for this one, we're going
to need events, I believe.
And this one is called actions
underscore, I believe--
LUKE DAVIS: Intent underscore
cancel in all caps.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Intent and then cancel.
No, no, I was right
the first time.
LUKE DAVIS: C-E-L.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: C-E-E-L.
LUKE DAVIS: Yes, ma'am.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Sweet, there we go.
LUKE DAVIS: All right.
And we want to
give it a training
phrase that's something like,
"no thanks" or "I'm done."
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Well,
before-- what does this do?
LUKE DAVIS: Oh, I'm
so glad you asked.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I know,
we get really excited.
LUKE DAVIS: So in addition
to training phrases
triggering these
things, triggering
these sorts of
events, we also have
things like events, which
are things that don't
have to be a user utterance.
It could be something else
about the program itself.
Like after a user tries to
sign in to an external service,
we'll get an event back saying
the user has successfully
authenticated with
this external service.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah,
and this one in particular
will override if somebody
says exit or goodbye,
Google's system
automatically handles it.
And so we want to go, no,
no, no, don't just exit.
We want to have our
own custom exit.
So we want to greet the--
or not greet the user.
What's the opposite
of greeting the user?
LUKE DAVIS: Aloha.
The other side of aloha.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: The other
side of aloha to the user.
We want to be able
to capture that.
And so this helps
kind of override
that functionality that
Google's system gives us,
which is a great one for
if we didn't have that,
it's good that it does.
But since we know about
this, let's do our own.
LUKE DAVIS: So we've got
some training phrases
that Jessica has added here.
We've got our exit
event that she's added.
And then down at
the bottom, we're
just going to enable webhook
fulfillment for this.
And we'll go build ourselves
a little exit handler.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Let me hit save.
OK, and then we'll
go into our code.
And scroll down.
I'm going to put this, actually,
after our welcome intent.
LUKE DAVIS: That feels
thematically appropriate.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah,
and this one is called,
was it capital?
LUKE DAVIS: I think you
capitalized it, yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I did, didn't I?
And what, it's going to take in.
LUKE DAVIS: So we'll
build the callback.
And the callback is going
to take the conversation.
And we could just
say, adios, amigo.
But we probably already
know the user's sign.
They've just told
us that they're
a designer or an
engineer or something.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
We do, don't we?
So we kind of--
you know what would be
great, is if we could--
LUKE DAVIS: If we could
use that in some way.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
LUKE DAVIS: If we could say,
see you later, engineer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That'd be fantastic.
LUKE DAVIS: I think
that would pretty great.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK, so
it seems like right here,
let me just do com dot end--
or close, sorry.
And then just put a
goodbye just to have this.
LUKE DAVIS: That sounds great.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Fantastic, so it
sounds like to be able to
do that, where we could go
goodbye, PM, goodbye,
engineer, is we
need to save that
actual piece of data.
LUKE DAVIS: Right, so how
are we going to do that?
How do we save data
in a conversation?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Well, I believe
that there is a property
that we could use.
It's not great for--
just a caveat, it's not
a large amount of memory
that you could use.
But something like this where
it's a simple, short string,
I think this would
be really sweet
where it's the user storage.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah,
it's very-- so there
are two kinds of ways built
into our calling library
to save data.
You can save data
within a conversation,
and you can save data
between conversations.
So the thing that Jessica
is alluding to is something
called com dot user dot storage.
It's just right on the
conversation object,
and you can just add
whatever you want there.
The limit is that I think
it's 10K of memory, something
in that zone.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I believe
so Something like that.
LUKE DAVIS: So it's
very, very small.
You shouldn't use it
for any big things.
But for little affordances
like this, it's perfect.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
LUKE DAVIS: So why don't we,
in the select sign intent,
go ahead and save this sign
that the user selected.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
That sounds great.
And so we do that by--
LUKE DAVIS: So before
we say horoscope,
we're going to want to say
com dot user dot storage dot--
so user storage is
actually just an object.
And when you save a thing,
a property on that object,
it'll be saved in
between conversations
on the com object itself.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: This
is the long-term storage.
LUKE DAVIS: Yes,
between conversations.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: What
do you want to call this?
LUKE DAVIS: Let's
just call it sign.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sign.
And we're going to
set this to the sign
that we're getting
from the parameters.
LUKE DAVIS: I think
that's brilliant.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK, perfect.
And so since we've done that,
now we could use that here.
LUKE DAVIS: Exactly.
So we're going to do
an existence check,
and we'll say if
there is a sign--
so if com dot user
dot storage dot sign--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Let's grab that.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh,
you're brilliant.
Much better engineer than me.
Com dot user dot storage.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
User dot storage.
LUKE DAVIS: And then I'll
just yank the sign property
right off of storage.
And then we can say, if sign--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
If it exists.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah,
yeah, if we have sign,
then we're going to
say com dot close,
because we're leaving
the conversation,
see you next time.
And then whatever the thing is.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Com
dot-- oh, I could just--
I'm going to use this.
There we go.
LUKE DAVIS: Oh yeah,
that's perfect.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah.
OK, so we want to say
see you next time.
LUKE DAVIS: See you next time
and then whatever their sign
is.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And sign.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
Lovely, lovely, lovely.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
And then if they don't have it--
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah, if
we don't have the sign,
then we'll want to say
something kind of generic,
just like see you next time.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Com dot close.
See you next time.
Looks like I might have--
how's that look?
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah, you want
to close those curlies?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
I'm missing-- yep.
Just one?
Oh no, there's one
and then there's two.
There, already had that one.
LUKE DAVIS: And then close
parens maybe possibly?
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Where?
LUKE DAVIS: At the end.
Lovely.
I think so.
Close parens, yeah, yeah.
Parens rather than curlies.
All right.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: There we go.
OK, so that looks good?
LUKE DAVIS: That
looks pretty good.
I'm feeling optimistic.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: You feel--
OK sweet, I'm going
to hit deploy.
And that way it
can go out there.
OK, so--
LUKE DAVIS: So this
strategy, we're
remembering salient
details about the user
so that they don't have
to enter the same thing
over and over and over again.
It's something that any
advanced voice user interface
designer is going to want to
include in their applications.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, well, it just it
makes it feel just
more personalized.
It makes it feel like
we know this action,
because as humans we definitely
personify some experiences.
I know if I see anything
with googly eyes
and if it looks like
there's a mouth,
I automatically
add like a feeling
that that thing is
a thing, a person.
And so our actions definitely
fall into that category.
People feel like, oh,
it's something I know.
So we could give that back.
Sweet, OK, so it's deployed.
LUKE DAVIS: All right,
we'll go check it out,
see if it all works.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Let's reset.
LUKE DAVIS: We'll talk
to our test, then.
COMPUTER: All right, getting
the test version of my test app.
LUKE DAVIS: All right,
so this is the first time
that we have booted up the
action after adding the com
user storage bit.
So Jessica is just going
to choose one of the signs
in order to save that thing
to your com user storage--
COMPUTER: Your
horoscope for today is--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Let me mute
that so you can keep going.
LUKE DAVIS: And then we're
going to leave the conversation
and come back and make sure
that it actually worked.
So if we say no thanks here--
COMPUTER: Great surprises
come in unexpected packages.
Would you like to
hear the horoscope--
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK, I wanted
to make sure that was done.
That way we could
have the audio.
OK, so now we're going
to click on no thanks.
COMPUTER: See you
next time, designer.
LUKE DAVIS: Nice.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
It remembered!
Wait, I'm not a
designer, but that's OK.
LUKE DAVIS: So now
that we have that,
we can actually use it not
just on that exit intent.
We can use it on the
default welcome intent.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Oh my gosh, so when
someone comes in
the second time,
we could be like,
I know who you are.
LUKE DAVIS: I know
what your horoscope is.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Nice, OK, perfect.
So let's go back to
Dialogflow, and then
let's go into our
code, which we're here.
OK cool, so we're
going to go back
to our welcome intent,
which is up here.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
we're going to just--
LUKE DAVIS: Take
advantage of the fact
that now we might actually
know what the user's sign is.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, so
instead of watching me type,
I just copy pasted
some code in here.
And so what's-- sweet--
what's happening here,
it's going to check to
see if that sign exists
in the storage.
It's going to grab that.
LUKE DAVIS: Exactly
like we did last time.
And it's going to do a fancy
thing where it grabs the sign
and then it capitalizes
the first character.
It's not super important
that you follow everything
that's happening on line 125.
It's just a little fancy thing,
a little fancy JavaScript.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: And
then after that we give them
the horoscope, because
that's most likely what
they want if they are
returning back to us.
They're going to want
to hear their horoscope.
So we go "This is your
horoscope already."
And if they're new, if
we don't have their sign,
then we still give
them the generic,
"Welcome to Silicon
Valley horoscope."
LUKE DAVIS: Exactly.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
OK, so let's deploy this,
and we can test that out.
LUKE DAVIS: So we're now
getting kind of close
to our ambitions
for the project.
We've shown you how to build
in these suggestion chips
as an affordance to the user.
We've shown you how to
handle exits more gracefully,
and handling maybe
some specific user
data that you might have saved.
We showed you how to save
that user data and com user
storage between conversations.
And now we're going
back and sprucing up
the actual default
welcome intent
itself based on whether or not
you've met the user before.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Exactly.
LUKE DAVIS: All these
things are going
to help kind of create the
magic of a voice user interface.
And we want to avoid, if we
can, kind of breaking the spell
by making the
conversation too jarring.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I love that.
Sweet, so it's been deployed.
Let's go to actions on
Google and test this out.
So this should, because we've
already been here before,
it should give me
the designer one.
LUKE DAVIS: It's exciting.
COMPUTER: All right.
Getting the test
version of my test app.
LUKE DAVIS: That's
awesome, it did it!
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: OK,
cool, so it gave us back
that we're a designer and
it gave us our horoscope.
And then it still
asks us a question,
if we want to hear something
else, which is great.
I'm going to put no thanks.
LUKE DAVIS: That sounds great.
COMPUTER: See you
next time, designer.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Sweet.
LUKE DAVIS: Awesome.
I feel really good about this.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA:
Yeah, I think we
built exactly what we wanted.
This is super cool.
LUKE DAVIS: Yeah, I'm
super happy with this.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Yeah, well,
thank you so much for watching.
We really appreciate it.
LUKE DAVIS: If you
enjoyed the show today,
you can like and
subscribe down below,
or comment and tell
us what we messed up.
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: I
know I made lots of typos.
So thank you so much
for bearing with me.
And please feel
free to follow us
on Twitter, on
Actions on Google,
and use the hashtag #AoGDevs.
That's where we publish
a lot of our content.
And we also have a
Reddit community too,
and we publish there as well.
So thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
LUKE DAVIS: Thank you.
Bye!
JESSICA EARLEY-CHA: Bye!
[MUSIC PLAYING]